okay okay it's like a year and I could
get in this [ __ ] her quest for a 10
second tattoo now I have a follower of
the Lord Jesus so I don't believe in the
devil's mark but hey you know it's a
game it's a game of this money so [ __ ]
it i had i do this give me a mystical
trophy oh [ __ ] okay um yes there's one
get here [ __ ] one cute huh [ __ ] why so
sad letter I dad here oh here we go oh
yeah yeah yeah judge judge that they
like that a night ok good very good ok
uh no no no oh hi i'm looking to get
majestic ok yep um oh [ __ ] it's a snake
it's just snakey I you need it you need
it oh wait to doc it's a bucket ok good
good good ok well its Nexus next oh [ __ ]
anime ok what's playing this plan is one
until ok oh we slow Oh Gideon though the
air ah ok ok that what else it takes a
scalpel that's fine that's fine with me
I'm a single book
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] mr. ribs here is the
tail and there's the quacker oh god I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry a murderous
fruit basket okay okay let's see this
will do this hey yeah yeah yeah baby
give me that fruit my god baby yeah baby
left let me touch your lips of my um let
me touch it lips with my thumb good
that's all [ __ ] I hope you learn from
this hi